hi my name is Justin Koh and I'm an
engineer on the Android wear team I'm
here today to tell you about how you can
make your app ready for the wrist with
Android wear let's take a look at how
developing for Android wear is different
than developing traditional Android apps
one key benefit of Android wear is
giving people the information they need
right when they need it we realize that
your Android device already does a lot
of this through notifications so we
decided to start by bringing those same
notifications to your wrist I'll show
you what I mean here I have my Nexus 5
I've installed the Android wear preview
app on it and I've paired it to my
emulated device I have a small app which
creates notifications with different
styles notice how the notification
appears on Android wear automatically I
can update the notification and the
changes are immediately bridged over
even better I can dismiss the
notification from my Android wear device
and it will disappear from my phone this
is a really powerful concept this means
that if your app post notifications
today it's already on your wrist it's
worth noting that all of this is
possible thanks to the notification
listener API that was added in Android
4.3 so let's talk about how to get
started developing for Android wear
first go to developer.android.com where
you can sign up for the Developer
Preview and browse the documentation you
should also download the system image
from the SDK manager to create an
Android virtual device with Android wear
finally install the Android wear a
preview app and run it on your Android
phone that is connected to your emulator
at this point you'll have your
development environment set up and ready
to go let's look at some code for an app
that invites people to events it
probably looks really familiar right
there isn't anything specific to Android
wear here I'm just using the
notification compat class from the
android support library to show a
notification I've also added an action
to my notification so I can tell my app
that I'll be attending the event this
action becomes available on my wrist so
I don't even have to take my phone out
of my pocket to respond instead I just
swipe over to the right and tap the
action that starts a service on the
phone that can add the event to my
calendar and then remove the
notification note that I could have you
the notification styles introduced in
Android 4.1 such as big picture style to
show a photo alongside the notification
text so that's really cool but with
great power comes great responsibility
automatically bridging notifications to
your wrist means it's extremely
important that you be considerate of
when and how you notify the user first
note that Android wear devices will not
vibrate for every notification that will
get annoying really quickly
only notifications which would vibrate
or make a sound on the phone will buzz
your wrist next it's important that
notifications be as contextually
relevant as possible for example you can
use the api's in Google Play services to
set up a geofence
and only post a notification when the
user is at home or you could use the
activity detection API to only send
notifications when the user is biking if
you have an app that generates a lot of
notifications like a chat or email
client you should give your user control
over when your notifications will make a
sound or vibrate finally you should take
advantage of the notification priority
field there are several buckets max high
default low and min setting the proper
priority helps the system show the most
relevant information at the right time
for more on what makes a good
notification see the design guidelines
on developer.android.com so that's one
way you can begin getting your app ready
for the wrist with Android wear by
optimizing your apps notifications
you'll be taking the first step to
making your app more wrist friendly
there are more api's in the Developer
Preview that will help you customize
notifications when they appear on
Android wear devices so check out the
documentation and other dev bytes
episodes for more on that and make sure
to look at the sample code in the
developer preview and the UX guidelines
on developer.android.com thanks and
happy coding